hello welcome to our Google+ experiment
here my name is David Brent and I'm here
with the lovely Cara warden sitting
beside me and we have a great group of
folks here joining us for our first ever
hang out and we're going to be talking
independent film and so as we begin we
want to go around the horn and we're
gonna start from left to right and have
everyone introduce themselves we'll
start there so if you can just say who
you are tell us where you're located it
may be just a little bit about your
current projects you know we just want
to keep that brief and let's keep this
movie we'll get into a little discussion
on independent film so we'll start with
you Christopher hi my name is
Christopher John Shaw and I'm in Sonoma
County California which is near Santa
Rosa and about an hour north of San Fran
I'm currently fundraising for two
projects right now one is a short it's a
faith-based short and one is the
feature-length film called youth group
and the short is club one-night stand
it's on Kickstarter right now and then
it's then you're up next John alright
I'm John Mercer I'm an editor yep okay
sorry some of the delay yes I'm John
Mercer I'm an editor based in Boston
Mass early working on a short film
called remember your death been in
post-production all summer and sort of
just wrapping things up for early August
so we'll have more on that student
Oakland all right he'll know where I'm
from Los Angeles
any of them an independent producer over
it's summertime media can you hear me
okay yes okay I'm working on 30 of Oz
right now it's an animated feature
raised our funds privately that make the
movie exactly a Michele from Glee in it
and that's going to take another year of
animation so we just started doing
another project for a kids show and I'm
always interested in people that are in
production how do we go about financing
hello I am Raffi as Dorian I am a video
editor in New York City
I'm also an independent filmmaker I've
made a bunch of short films some music
videos some abstract pieces and I am
trying to get my first feature film into
into kind of pre pro and still working
on it because I work full time as a
reality TV editor in the new york city
so it's kind of like bounce think of to
is a little tough but I'm hoping to get
some time soon and then do and get my
first feature film underway Ronis I
think you're up next because we have we
have Robert just kind of sitting in just
as an avatar he just wants to watch so
you're up next Ross filling for the
avatar can get your hammer yeah so I'm
Ross pretty and I live in Port Townsend
Washington and we're we're doing a lot
of projects I have a future project that
I'm working on I the TV series I'm
currently developing or pitching down in
Los Angeles
I am currently developing some pretty
interesting business models for
independent filmmakers in particular and
you guys strange to have like a black
screen so this is me and my untarnished
truth and unexpectedly saw this on
Twitter I'm sherry handler I work with
independent filmmakers to figure out how
to build audiences and identities for
themselves and use social media I'm in
the middle of putting together a digital
book called selling your film without
some in your soul it's about its case
studies of filmmakers who have been
navigating distribution on their
either through hybrid distribution DIY
or using file-sharing networks to put
their work out today we got a script
back on what this trailer is going to
look like so I'm really really excited
typically we'll have it in the next week
or so and we have a blog that's going
that every Tuesday and Thursday we
release some information from the book
or something about our sponsors just to
get people sort of knowledgeable about
what to expect in the book it'll be
released in mid September during IFP
week in New York and I'm gonna be in New
York during that time sitting on a panel
and IFP week and hopefully meeting
people who are hanging out in New York
at the same time you're that Raffy oh
yeah my name is Jonathan Schafer I have
shot a feature film a couple shorts I'm
currently working on a spec or Showtime
maybe I hope that's what I'm hoping to
pitch it to a near future dystopian shot
live-action that we convert into
animation am I getting my steal again
yes yeah now you get now you give this
this feel that officially so via okay um
Sylvia Franklin based in Chicago I am a
filmmaker I'm currently co-producing a
feature right now entitled things never
said it's on Facebook we're on Twitter
we have an IMDB page we actually just
completed principal photography on the
feature and and moving into the second
phase which is raising money for post
and all that good stuff it's not my film
I didn't write it and directed its
magnetic filmmakers effort an actress
that but television is my background for
the most part as a writer and producer
and I'm just branching out into the
digital world and storytelling and
strategy and having all those sort of
disciplines intersect
awesome well this is this is a great
grouping of folks we have here we want
to want to thank each of you for for
sort of hanging out with us here
Christopher you know how often do
independent film trailers really get you
excited where you're gonna want to get
out and see the movie not very often
actually they they usually don't look
that interesting to me to be honest with
you what is it about the most
independent film trailers that look
unappealing to you I think they tend to
all look kind of the same like it seems
to be the same kind of story
love triangle or something like that and
it just they just had that indeed kind
of look and feel to them that looks the
same as so many others John John Mercer
what do you what do you love about
independent films well it's kind of a
big question I mean I would say a lot of
the times I I enjoy making them more
than I enjoy seeing them which is sort
of unfair but I mean you know for me I I
enjoy working on things that are fairly
connected with or that sort of my
feelings that I I I know someone or or
its story clothes or something like that
I think you sort of get that connection
with an independent and you don't
necessarily get that with the larger
film that's just sort of like my
personal angle on you know and sherry
can you jump in I mean what do you love
about independent film I mean you know
you you you're so so gifted and so
talented we're sure that you would have
the opportunity to work on on larger
films but but you choose to work on
smaller films yeah I think that you give
me more credit and then I
I have often said and I think a lot of
people in the industry don't really
believe me that I do not have any
aspirations to work in the studio system
I have no aspirations to be a studio
employee in fact I see the studio system
is crumbling before my eyes and it's
like running into a burning building I
wouldn't do that I think that it's gonna
be much more about smaller audiences but
much more connected audiences to have
the direct connection to those people to
have them care about you as a filmmaker
in addition to the way you tell stories
and want to support you in that way and
that's I think what attracted me to to
independent film as it is now I mean I
always watched it I always watched
independent film when I you know had a
chance and it was in a place where I was
not when I lived in Russia but I really
like independent filmmakers I just like
to be around you know creative people I
recognized very early on that I'm not
one of those people I can't make films
but I like to watch them and I like to
be around people who can do that but I
do have this talent for talking to
audiences having direct connections to
people being able to to bring them in to
something that I'm really excited enough
it's also a reason why I can't work with
every film that comes that's presented
to me an opportunity that's presented to
me because if I don't like the film if I
can't connect to it or feel like it was
really a good story it's gonna be really
hard for me to go out and find an
audience because I don't do it through
advertising I have to talk to these
people I have to get in you know it into
their community and really getting them
excited about it if I'm not excited I
just can't fake they know the reason I'm
there is to use them if I really don't
believe in what I'm saying so I had to
learn very early on to be careful about
the projects that I picked to work on
because when you're standing there and
you're talking and you're trying to be
believable you can't do it well if you
don't believe it yourself so I that's
another reason why I think that I'm not
to the studio model because in the
studio mode you don't have to you know
if you have to support whatever film
they give you they don't care if you
personally like it or not it's one of
their slate and you've got to go out and
work it the only way to do that is to do
it through one-way communication through
advertising trying to get stories place
all the stuff that separates you from
the direct people who would read it or
watch it you're trying to create hoop
line-height and buzz and I don't like
those words because what you're saying
is creating air around a project that
may or may not really deserve it and I
don't want to fool people into going to
see trick them and they're going to see
it the first weekend because they're so
excited and so they find out we pulled a
fast one on them and take in their money
I just that's not my mentality it's not
a mindset that I want to have and so I
don't have any aspirations to working
with big films with lots of people law
and all that background in it you know
Jonathan
spirits is full do you want to add some
of your thoughts well as a filmmaker I
mean I my goal is to tell a story and so
whatever does that best if it's if it
can be done in an indie setting awesome
because that means you know it gives me
more freedom in it and it's a lot easier
a lot less you know people have an
opinion it's not that's not good I mean
obviously more voices make something
better oftentimes but at the same time
there's a lot of things that I'm not
able to do just because the money's not
there and so I don't I mean I don't I
don't really excited one way or the
other necessarily although I do
completely agree with what Jerry said
about being passionate about something I
don't think I could ever take a project
that I didn't love just because of how
much work it takes to do any of it
and so we're you're sort of reconnecting
with us here can you can you tell us you
know what why you love independent film
well I just think that it gives it gives
you another platform
to tell stories you know we're so
fortunate and unfortunate at the same
time in that you know mainstream
television even cable only sort of
appeals to a very narrow kind of defined
audience and for people who have taste
outside of that there really isn't an
outlet for the stories that they may
want to see and I just think independent
film gives people the option sort of
peeking into those stories those lives
those characters and to an earlier
question would I go see a mainstream
film or a Hollywood film or independent
it just depends on what the subject
matter is but I I find myself
increasingly as a woman and as a woman
of color there's just nothing out there
that really speaks to me
and I'm definitely wanting to see more
of those kinds of stories so I mean you
know one thing that that goes through my
head is is is I often see folks that say
that they're tired of the franchise's
that they're tired of the sequels you
know that they're tight you know that
they're tired in one end but at the same
time when it comes down to their
decision if they're gonna support a
small independent film or if they're
gonna see one of these larger films you
know obviously the money talks and
obviously they go in that direction
curious if you guys have any comments on
that yourself yeah go ahead Christopher
I'm not sure how I'm missing it but I
actually don't see a lot of trailers or
anything for independent films and like
I said before the ones that I do see
seem to all kind of look the same so
maybe there should be more availability
to an outlet to actually see some of
their trailers for them yeah where would
you where would you look like this is
this is a question I would you know be
very interested to hear the answer to I
me because I know that there there are
services that do nothing but propagate
trailers all over the place
for thousands of dollars for indie film
distributors what sites are you looking
at online where you don't see that like
the trailers don't reach you or how
would I go about reaching you if I was
going to place my trailer and I thought
it was something you'd be interested in
to be honest I haven't done a lot of
searching online I'm just saying in
general in the general public
most of the advertisements we're seeing
are the blockbusters or the ones that
are more well known and not smaller
independent films I mean would be yeah
like TV or movie theater when you're
seeing previews and that kind of thing
unless you got like the major
oscar-nominated stars or something that
it it's they're just kind of few and far
between that you even see them right
millions of dollars are spent on that
that's why you don't see small
independent films in fact that was shot
the other night when I saw a trailer for
another earth and it was on television I
was like man you know they they're
really cranking up I think it's they're
really cranking up the money to put ads
on television to reach to reach
audiences you know and we have a new
visitor we have Michael oh hey Michael
where are you joining us room oh I'm I'm
in Portland I was actually just looking
at my Twitter feed and noticed you guys
were doing this and wanted to drop in
I've never done a Google hangout before
so it's kind of my version the version
riot um anybody I'm gonna I'm not gonna
be able to hang on too long dude when I
leave please don't take it the wrong way
I just I had an appointment but I I
happy to be here you guys talking about
trailers yeah you know let's pose the
question to you if you have a choice if
you have a Hollywood trailer on one side
and an independent film trailer on the
other side you know
which movie are you going to see you're
talking about on a and I in my first
exposed to this on the internet or some
other way
there's trout these trailers yeah most
likely because for the independent film
is probably good it's probably going to
be on online where you come across it
but let's say you have a movie that they
care and I loved a better life which is
a great independent film you have that
trailer in front of you or you have
Harry Potter which which one are you
going to see well that's easy it's it's
gonna be a better life only because uh
well I'm not a big fan of the other film
that's franchise but you know as I think
I'm read as opposed to supporting indie
film I think I think you know Joe
Sixpack or random random person um is
obviously gonna go with the thing that
they know looks more professional or
they already know of the franchise or
the people or whatever it's just it's
it's just you know that's just the way
it works it's harder for you coming you
know from the abyss
no one knows any actors in your film no
knows who you are no one's heard of this
phone before you're nobody unless you
have a amazing still or someone else
that that the perks unless it's being
recommended to you from you a friend
then why would they why would they watch
the trailer you know you time watching
the trailer or going to the film you
know getting to that point where you're
gonna you're gonna actually yeah go and
see the film well I need the trailers
bit then then I just don't you know if
it's a good trailer it's a good trailer
and there's an order to doing that -
that's like a whole thing in itself um
sorry I didn't mean to hog up all the
airwaves hey I can ramble
you should stop me when it's oh that's
good
that's good let me throw this out to you
guys like right now if you had to name
five must-see independent films
I'm just curious which one of you guys
the first one that could raise your hand
and say okay I have five must-see
independent films Jonathan one
I really enjoyed Charlie Bartlett and
these aren't in any particular order
there is a great Japanese film called
departures ted hopes movie American
Splendor blew me away there's a Polish
brothers film called North Fork and I
guess I ran for off and it just not
absolutely knocked me my socks off
I have to one is the butterfly circus
directed by Joshua Weigel written by him
and his wife Rebecca the link I just put
there in butterfly circus calm and then
the other one is on YouTube it's called
spider are those ones short yes and
they're actually in the process of
either finishing up writing or making a
feature for the butterfly circus where's
the chat where you couldn't find the
link I'm sorry there's some there's a
chat feature in the lower left hand
corner there's a button next to the
YouTube button this track I have a head
one this is out now or at least I was in
Portland anyways which doesn't say much
: they're pretty good it's it's a I
think it's an indie film yeah it's it's
somewhat indie film so it's a common one
it's like a it's like a Norwegian film
or something like that it looks like
Robert is typing Robert Pilkington
and he's saying number one rubber number
two huh sure remember your death which
is a short and number four troll hunter
yeah it's like also John I know that
like a ton of um Sundance films that
were bought during the festival will be
coming out in the next four months so
you were probably like another earth is
one of them pariahs another one may see
you Marlene RC whatever it was that Ted
helped to produce is coming out as well
soon so it takes about this long nine
months from being bought at the Sundance
Film Festival to actually coming to a
theater near you but they're all coming
out in August September October time and
Syria Mina is it hard for you to find a
good independent film um yeah where I am
right now it is because I'm in Northwest
Florida and a teeny tiny beach town no
they're not big in the independent film
care I was shocked when The Kids Are
Alright actually was playing in the
theater for a week or two because that's
not the kind of fare they would normally
have I expect the Sarah Palin film to
show any minute it's the local theater
just because it's a military town and
you know there are very good public in
here so now I think if an independent
film isn't on Netflix or somewhere
online where I can watch it iTunes or
Amazon or something like that then I
have to wait until it is unless the
filmmaker sends me a DVD I can come back
to the whole trailer question it sort of
makes a difference where you see your
film so I think maybe the more
appropriate question is given a choice
would you film in more of a national
chain or an independent theater and I
think if you're watching the majority of
your comes in to benefit are you more
likely to see in trailers and that's
sort of what's going to make
so John well I mean the place she lives
Howdy's an independent theater which was
on Owens case John that's an issue of
where Isis are located I know in Chicago
a lot of these sort of mainstream
Hollywood type theaters are around but
there's very few
arthouse type movie theaters that cater
to the independent market so you have to
as filmmaker you're thinking well where
am I going to show this in my own
community in my own hometown we have to
go do the exhibitors that need to fill
up those theaters when they don't have
these big blockbusters you know around
yeah you know I guess I want to jump in
there for a second I know we're gonna
come we're gonna come to you John Paul
Ryan's right after this but what's
interesting is is is what we're seeing
more here in the Los Angeles area and I
believe around the country is we're
seeing like around the holidays
especially like you know Halloween comes
to mind where a lot of stores will pop
up you know for Halloween only and they
become like these successful stores just
you know where they take over some
novelty store you know not with these
stores you know but we haven't quite
seen that all the way at big movie
theaters yet where instead of having the
big films for the entire week where
maybe they just shuffle in special
events you know or one-day screenings or
just one-off screenings but I'm
wondering you know if we're gonna get to
that point where we see more of that you
know where we see more mainstream
theaters finding a home for four four
four four smaller films and giving them
the chance I think that's an interesting
situation that I think that's the best
thing in future possibly but I think
that sort of gets back to you know the
concert analogy you know it was a kid on
the road and trying to reach people like
that
and I think you know for some films that
that does work I mean certainly Kevin
Smith for example had success with that
but I would say you know someone who's
spent some time as a musician I don't
know that that's really the best thing
for our industry because it's exhausting
and not always sustainable that's yeah
I'm not too sure that the traveling
filmmaker I'm not sure that that's a
future where we're all able to make a
living and make a thumbs-up we want to
make yeah well what about like movies
going straight to your set-top box you
know video a video on demand
I think that's that's I mean that's
great then that's obviously working now
but going back to the trailer issue then
how are you finding out about films are
you watching one on the DVD before your
you know video on-demand starts or are
you just watching apps right now I think
you're just watching ads yeah yeah I
think there needs to be some sort of
system or a new model in place to
publicise one those lines the trailers
may be again
I don't know independent filmmakers or
some sort of distributor can just start
sending trailers directly to your your
own set-top box and you just see it like
you would any commercial if you're
signing up or service so to speak well I
think there needs to be actually an
education and consumers as well because
I think consumers are used to just
taking whatever people give them they're
not used to having to search for
anything or look for anything and if you
really want to watch an independent film
there's no excuse for not being able to
find out information if you have you
know circles there are many many sites
there are sites that are just for
trailers and iTunes is one of them where
you you know that a trailer addict and a
movie trailer net and all that kind of
stuff that if you're really interested
in finding out about new films you can
go to those and they exist and you can
get your your trailer up there I think
people are too used to being fed it on
their television
so they go I don't know anything about
the new films because I haven't seen a
trailer because it hasn't played on my
television and now that everything's
moving online I think we'll have more
people curious doing more research being
open to looking for things that they
want to find out instead of waiting for
it to come to them
I still think people are going to need
some sort of packaging to deliver that
citizen though because there are film
enthusiasts and people are always going
to find a way to find new content but
you know if you're looking at expanding
an independent market out to you know
include your your casual viewer sort of
like the casual gaming market is
expanding right now then there has to be
some sort of aggregator and iTunes is
great it's all there but he's sort of I
don't know these stumble upon things in
iTunes here we go there with from a link
or with an attention well more and more
these sites are going to be searching
for what you watched before and they're
going to be much more intuitive about
the things that you're interested in and
then serve those things to you which I
think it's a good thing and a bad thing
it means some of your privacy is being
monitored and some people don't like
that when on the other hand it serves to
you things that they know you'd be
interested in and doesn't and they don't
serve to you things that you wouldn't so
you wouldn't be bothered by a general
app you'll be bothered by things that
they know you're interested in based on
I mean what we're doing right now on
Google Hangouts I'm almost positive is
being trapped in some way to know who we
hung out with and I don't know if we're
being monitored for what we're talking
about but people know we use Google you
know we're doing it through certain ads
we might be putting certain links up on
the chat bar or whatever and all of that
information can be mined and tracked
back to us and then we're fed more of it
scary like the music wherever is going
with music well let's say hello to mr.
John Paul rice how are you John Kim can
you wanna move I don't know if you can
hear me at all
we can yeah we can we can hear you you
know I bought my mic little HP laptop
nice to tell the tell us what you love
about independent film John well I love
the opportunity to be in a group like
this and people who are like passionate
about what they're doing trying to
figure out what is the next stage of
distribution as well as getting our
content out there for me it's being able
to create stories that your you feel are
important to tell and not having a
lawyer or a distributor or another
studio executives water down your
material because that's essentially what
they do it every step of the way so you
know it gives me great pleasure and
pride to be able to be a part of the
community of people that are trying to
work together at the same time rather
than to compete against one another and
all of us are trying to do what we love
which is tell a great story
so John given the choice would you go
see a Hollywood film or an independent
film would that depend on a piece I mean
for me it's it's it's it the subject
matter really appeals to me if the story
is interesting to me I mean I I have to
be quite frank in some cases I do love
independent film but I don't necessarily
just watch every independent film it's
really for something to to speak to me
through a trailer or through a review is
why I want to see something about this
film possibly also is when a person of
authority who I put authority in to say
for example like jet load the film talk
he talks about a movie that he loves and
he tells me why I trust his opinion and
so I inquired to go and see that film
you know
Christopher's or anything you just
wanted that just you know I love what
you have to share I'm just wondering if
there's anything you want to kind of
throw out here you know I don't know
there's a specific question but just
said anything going through your mind as
some of the things that everyone's bring
it up here well I would have to say that
I do agree with some of what sherry said
as well as people what John said
regarding you know she's right we if
we're interested and we do need to look
more and then John's right to the
general population might not even think
to look for the content so for them
there needs to be some kind of packaging
so I would agree with both of those
perspectives to some degree um and some
thoughts uh having in two things one one
thing that a Hollywood film has in its
favor is big budget you know blockbuster
is um you know if it's a type of film
that everyone's gonna watch or if it's
like a piece of you know down the
culture of that year I offer more logic
you know I want to see a film that
everyone's talking about just to take
part in conversation sometimes I'm
definitely going to see films for that
easy
those good in that but and that's one
that's one thing that a blockbuster film
has over an indie film because you know
more people are gonna see it so Dean
so more people are gonna see it just
alone but one thing that an indie film
has in its favor that a blog post you
can't do is because of the smaller
budget it doesn't have to appeal to a
larger audience and so it can appeal you
know very very directly to a small
earnings and we've seen all this before
be it you know an ice-hockey movie you
know someone who's into ice hockey's
gonna go stay that movie because they're
into it
I mean it works with a million different
mini genres and that's that's one thing
you can do with in any film is appeal to
a very small audience but appeal to them
and in a big way you know why cause you
can't do that
thank you Michael I who was John was
that you were gonna add something there
yeah I just wanted to say that there's I
mean I wanted to share with the group
something that we're going to be doing
this fall and that is we're launching a
website for our company we're we went
out and bought the domains for the names
of our films and what we're going to do
is a splash screen just a one page which
gets the trailer so that it can be
cached at Google but everything is going
to forward to the main company's site
and we're going to use dynamo or
district dystrophy as a player for
streaming only to start with the film
and I'm only saying this because it was
brought up at the pixel photo studios
when we were doing the future of film
curation about Lukas McNally mentioned
this but I really think this is
something that independent filmmakers
should take heed and that is for any
review that you get online you should
talk to the blogger or the reviewer
who's doing the review of your movie and
see if they would be cool at the end of
the review to insert the embedded code
for that video so that people who want
to see the movie right away can do so
and not have to hunt or search for it or
wait for it I think this is a very easy
and simple thing to do and I've already
had a couple of bloggers that have
tested this with in terms of asking them
they think it's a great fantastic idea
and they're ready to do it I also think
filmmakers for independence need to get
a Vimeo plus account and that's
something I cost maybe 60 bucks a year
but to get reviews internationally
especially when
are going to be launching a website
you'll be able to send that link with a
password-protected code so that you can
send it off to you know Germany or down
in Latin America and they'll be able to
review your film possibly in another
language and yet still and add the video
for your entire film that people can buy
especially now that PayPal is available
I think it over under 80 countries
what's the name of the international
review site well no no not the
international review site I'm saying
that for your video it would be
vimeo.com di Meo yeah and you can go on
there set up a free account but the for
the Plus account it gives you the option
to upload up to five gigabytes per week
of video okay you know something we want
to throw out to you shape Cherie since
we have you here do you feel like a lot
of filmmakers that work on smaller films
you know let's say budgets under
$250,000 are they spinning their wheels
trying to get their film in the theaters
or like going the festival route and
spending however many months trying to
get their film the theaters are they
spinning their wheels I don't think it
has to do with budget level of the film
the production part um it's better but
you better have money safe for going
into theaters if that's really what you
want because minimum you're going to be
spending about fifty thousand with a
service company to do maybe ten cities
maybe and then that doesn't even count
for having a publicist that you're gonna
because the whole reason that you want
to have your film in a theater is to get
reviews so that it can help to feed your
ancillary sales when it's finished
you know even if you have a distributor
who's it's gonna be really rare to find
their distributor is gonna take a
children for two thousand dollar film
and put as much or more of that to put
it in a theater unless they really
really think that there's going to be a
return and
and even if there's a return and more
for them that doesn't mean you're
getting anything for it they'll probably
give you like the ten thousand over
advance and see what happens so you know
it's like John would say every film is
different every film has a different
plan that kind of stuff I think that the
only reason your films should be in a
theater is in order to get good reviews
and if it can't it good reviews tiny
mainstream reviews then you're wasting
your time because then you're gonna
really you're spending all this money to
be in a theater to get bad reviews or
get no reviews and no one shows up
that's not even a good business plan so
I think if you're doing low-budget films
you should be looking more at online
distribution more at self distribution
more at users your theatrical rather
than then spending the money to put it
in a theater yourself and hope for the
best
you have a mole sherry what do you mean
look behind you you know well you know I
guess that should be bed time for some
of us here and you know let's just go
down the line if you guys have any final
thoughts and we'll just wrap this up and
thank you guys for joining us go ahead
Mike no that's just it's the cat sorry
Oh beautiful
everybody has their children yeah see
now you got cats well we want to thank
each of you guys for joining us where
we're in the dark now so I guess the
curtains are closing
you know we're gonna take this and we're
gonna hopefully find a way to post this
online we want to thank you for for
sharing your thoughts with us and as we
wrap up does anyone have any final
thoughts they do want to add John is
that okay I see here and then we'll wrap
up yeah I just yeah there's a gentleman
I don't know some of you probably heard
about him Justin Eugene Evans he had a
film it was it's been covered over all
over this week on Votto I think I'm
pronouncing it right Votto net yes oh
yeah he's had over 800,000 down loads
today since they released it this is a
movie with James Cromwell an Academy
Award nominated actor all the
distribution deals that he received were
essentially taking all of his rights
away for pennies and what he and Votto
are getting ready to do is launch into a
new phase of distribution for
pay-per-view both on cable and on
streaming and I would make a strong
effort everybody out here as a feature
film to contact Jamie King and his
business partners over voto to introduce
yourselves that's that's something I'm
doing right now so yeah I've actually
been into you about that I've had some
recent experience with Votto myself with
a short film we put our short film on on
Votto did you know it hasn't seen a huge
success on it um but we hadn't really
promoted it much you know if anybody
doesn't matter that you can I cannot
elaborate but it's a torrent site it's a
site it's kind of like a pirate day but
Phillip filmmakers willingly put their
phones on there it's the Polly go it's a
legal way to distribute your films right
um the idea is again a lot of people too
you know we enter we interview Jamie
king of auto net you know when that was
here and that was recently that was in
the last few months I believe I want to
say April May and that range so you know
if you're familiar with film cars calm
you can go through those archives and
and it's in the last couple months we
did that so let's go around the horn
here Christopher thank you for joining
us that's Christopher Sean Shaw mr. John
Paul rice let me I guess let me click on
everybody Thank You Christopher thank
you thank you for joining us John Paul
rice thank you for joining us in the
dark John Marshall you thank you John
you were the first one to join us we
appreciate John I'm the East Coast yeah
absolutely we got this whole thing going
here tonight Michael Michael thank you
and thank you all thank you Michael
thank you and that sweet cab that you
have there with you and you're right
you're still in the daylight you still
have that golden hour there behind you
look good it's a Northwest that's what
uh beautiful it's gorgeous I here in the
winter it's awful though because it gets
its start
really nice to meet you all oh you got
it thank you for meeting you guys thanks
again I hope we could do this again soon
you got it
sherry thank you for coming out of the
dark forest and saying hello and and and
for sort of you know keeping the family
at bay for a little bit but you know we
we wish the whole family a good night
and we'll talk to you in September as
well yes it's time for bed it's like
after 10 o'clock here so oh yes you will
and Sylvia don't be a you have a good
night our girl is Chicago thank you
likewise likewise it's very cool
all right we're signing off we'll see
you guys soon